all right the top 40 quarterback
countdown we're up to number 15 with tom
brady earlier in the show we discussed
drew brees disgust may be the right word
spelled differently some people are
disgusted by the presence of brady and
brees that low on the list just like
they were last year we got some feedback
from twitter at tim shaw222 you're great
chris sims but tb12 deserves a number
10 to 12 ranking from last year numbers
aren't everything which you let your
listeners know receivers weren't getting
separation and they lost their center
last year no decent tight end and julian
edelman was banged up offense was
conservative because the defense was so
good so is it that brady's reduction in
performance had something to do with the
fact that the team around him just
wasn't very good at least on the
offensive side of the ball chris
well those are the facts of the matter
certainly but i mean it's not like i'm
going to sit here and go oh that was the
worst offense in football i mean it was
nothing like that yeah they just weren't
as dominant as years past certainly and
all those you know issues with the
offense are real but i blocked that out
i don't care i really don't i don't sit
there and try to look at all that and
then blame it on the quarterback or
anything like that makes he makes a lot
of good points uh tim shaw 2-2-2 but at
the same time what i would tell him and
you know we'll get into it more tomorrow
and the rest of this week there's guys
right now first off there's just a lot
of good quarterbacks in football like a
lot of really good talented quarterbacks
and yeah there's guys at this point of
this career where yeah brady might have
experienced more experience than them
but their his experience does not
outweigh
the playmaking ability of some of the
guys that he has in front of them that
we'll see here coming up during the week
so that's really where i weigh it and uh
yes i realized those were real issues
but i think you could sit there and i
wish tim could come watch some film to
me where we'd watch it together and he'd
go oh okay yeah chris you are right
brady did leave some completions and
some yards and some moments that you
know he could have really you know
made a big strike in in a game and
didn't do it and uh i think that would
that would be a reality if i could watch
them film with some people
it really is a golden age of
quarterbacks and there are a bunch of
great quarterbacks right now in the nfl
and we should appreciate and enjoy this
moment where there are some guys at or
above the age of 40 who are still
getting it done and then a cluster of
great young quarterbacks coming up
through the ranks and the real question
is will colleges continue to produce
great quarterbacks will nfl teams
continue to just use the college
quarterbacks the way they were used in
college they finally figured out instead
of trying to jam the square peg into the
round hole we're just going to take the
guy that we like in college and let him
do at the nfl level what he did at
college which is why we liked him in the
first place we're not going to change
him and i think that's contributed to
why there's so many great quarterbacks
right now all right at joe bucks fan
which is the twitter handle for one of
the leading tampa bay buccaneers news
and information sites rank ready 15th
12th ninth who cares about the number
sim says brady can make all the throws
and he reads defenses like a super
genius that's good enough for joe as for
perspective on the upgrade sims has
jameis winston at number 33. so hey from
the buccaneers perspective they're up 18
spots they're happy with that
well yes and you know that those are my
my guys that you know at joe buck's fan
they're they're good people and good
good people all together um but yeah
that's the point you could still win a
super bowl with brady if people really
think brady's still a top five six seven
eight quarterback no that's insane if
you're trying to put them in you know
the list of some of the top quarterbacks
right now and their ability to make
plays but of course you can still win a
super bowl and again you know it's about
a team this is the one thing i'm trying
to beat into everybody's brains through
this in 2016 mike i know you've heard me
say this i'm going to say it again
though i don't care
the worst quarterback in football won
the super bowl literally and
realistically the worst quarterback in
football because they had a team around
him and yes he was smart and he knew how
to manage the game and i'm talking about
peyton manning but go back and look
anybody it's nine touchdowns 17
interceptions there's not much more that
needs to be said about that and he
couldn't really push the ball down the
field that doesn't make me proud to say
that about peyton manning who's one of
the three greatest of all time in my
eyes but it just shows you again we put
the quarterback too much on the pedestal
for the reasons the team win or loses or
whatever it may be
and uh you can certainly still win a
super bowl with tom brady or drew brees
but it's drew brees at number 16 that
sparks this question from chris rosvaglu
michael thomas is not the best receiver
in the league because he has drew brees
throwing him the football that's a quote
that chris rosglevloo has attributed to
chris sims chris when have you said
michael thomas is not the best receiver
in the league because he has drew brees
throwing in the football because the
point is
if brees is so good and it diminishes
michael thomas why is he number 16 on
your list so the basic argument is you
can't have it both ways defend yourself
well hey listen nice name chris okay i
like your first name but i mean those
words never came out of my mouth that
that's he's gonna have to show me that
quote or play back a video then
now have i said michael thomas is not
the best receiver in the league because
he's got drew brees and sean payton yeah
certainly you know but again hey drew
brees is really good we know that all
right here's some things for you teddy
bridgewater had as many 30-plus yard
completions as drew brees did and he
played five games they were 5-0 again
chris hey other chris
they the the saints don't move on from
top ten quarterbacks that tells you they
don't think he's in the top ten so yes
there's 15 other best quarterbacks and
michael thomas is not the best receiver
in football to me i'm sorry i think he's
awesome but here's the last point again
other than they don't move on from top
ten quarterbacks if you're still in the
top ten they let you keep playing for
their team but the big thing is too are
you don't think some of the top
quarterbacks in football would not have
better stats than drew brees if they
played that same offense you're crazy
again patrick mahomes in 2017 was the
top-rated quarterback in football alex
smith all the time well holmes went
times two the show's over
shut up
i can't help it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports